[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN GORNER: So thank
you for filling the house.
I'm really impressed
that TensorFlow
is getting so much attention.
But I think the
technology deserves it.
So I'm happy about that.
So today, or yesterday,
we built a neural network
for recognizing
handwritten digits.
And we went through
dense neural networks
and convolutional
neural networks.
And today, I want to build with
you another kind of network,
a recurrent neural network.
So let's go.
A couple of reminders
from yesterday.
You remember, we started with
this initial one layer neural
network.
And I need you to
remember the formula
for one layer of
a neural network
because we will be using it.
So we were reading in pixels.
But it works for any
input vector, of course.
And you remember, we
said that the neurons
do weighted sums of all of
their inputs, they add in bias,
and they feed that through
some activation function.
Here, softmax.
It can be another function.
It's just a function,
value in, value out.
But usually, in neural networks,
it's a non-linear function.
And we wrote this one
layer neural network
using a matrix multiply,
blah, blah, blah,
we've seen all that,
as this formula.
And you remember, we did
this not for just one image,
but we actually
wrote this formula
processing 100 images at a time.
So in x, we have
a batch of images,
a whole batch, 100 images.
And then x times w are all the
weighted sums for our neurons.
We add the biases.
We feed that through
our activation function.
And we obtain a
batch of predictions.
So in our case, since we were
classifying handwritten digits,
those predictions
are 10 numbers,
which are the probabilities of
these digits being a 0, a 1, 2,
3, and so on.
And so we obtained
those probabilities
as the outputs of
our 10 neurons.
OK, so whenever you
see this formula,
we will see it
again a lot today,
you think, one layer
of a neural network.
OK?
And then also, what I
need you to remember
is that once we get our output
from the neural network,
the way we train it is
that we give it examples.
It produces some prediction.
And then we say, no, no, no, no,
no, that's not what we wanted.
This is what you should predict.
We give it the correct answer.
And to do that, we have to
encode this correct answer
in a similar format.
So it's called-- it's a
very basic type of encoding.
It's called one hot encoding.
And basically here, if
we have 10 categories,
specifying one answer category
means encoding it as 10 0s,
but just one 1 somewhere in the
middle, and the index of the 1
here, it's at index 6.
Means that the correct
answer was a 6, OK?
So in this shape, it
becomes possible to compute
a distance between what
the network predicts
and what we know to be true.
And that distance, we call
that our error function.
Or sometimes, it's
called the loss function.
That's what we use to
guide our training.
So during training, we give it
an example, produces an output.
We say, no, no, no,
that's not what we wanted.
Compute the distance between
what the network says
and what we know to be true.
And from that distance,
we derive the gradient.
And then, we follow
the gradient.
And that modifies the
weights and biases.
And that's what
training is about, OK?
So now, let's look at
this neural network.
So it should look familiar.
It's a vector as an input.
It has a middle layer using
the hyperbolic tangent
as an activation function.
So we've seen the
sigmoid last time,
which is let's say the simplest
possible function going
from 0 to 1 continuously.
The hyperbolic tangent is the
simplest possible function
going from minus 1
to 1 continuously.
It's just a sigmoid shifted.
And then, a second
layer, which is a softmax
layer so that we
read something out.
But the specificity is
here that the output
of this intermediate
green layer is actually
fed back in the next
time step in the inputs.
So the real input into one cell
of a recurrent neural network
is the input concatenated to
the output of the inner layer
from the previous step.
And we call this the state.
So it's actually
a state machine.
You feed it inputs.
It produces outputs.
But you also feed it a state.
It produces an output state,
which you feed back in,
in the next time step.
And that's why it's called
a recurrent neural network,
it's because it is
applied on time sequences.
At each step in time, you
feed in one input vector,
concatenate it to
the previous state.
Turn the crank once.
That produces some outputs from
this middle layer, as well as
a result. And you feed
that back as the new input
state for the next
x input, which
you have in your sequence.
So it can be represented.
I'm showing you
the neurons inside.
But here, it's basically the API
of one recurrent neural network
cell.
It has an input.
It has an output, which
you then usually feed
into a softmax layer
to make sense of it,
to produce predictions.
I mean, probabilities.
And it has an input state
that produces an output
state that you loop back
in as the input state.
That's the state machine part.
OK?
So now, well yes, and
the parameter for this
is the internal size
of this middle layer.
That's what is adjustable.
Usually, your input is
whatever your input is.
And your output is whatever
you're trying to predict.
So those are not
adjustable parameters.
So here it is
written in equations.
Again, the input
is the real input
at time t concatenated
to the previous state.
Then, we feed that through.
Here, you should recognize
one layer of a neural network.
You should recognize
this formula
using the hyperbolic tangent
as an activation function.
So I put it over there.
And this produces
an output, Ht, which
is both used as our new
state and as the output that
will be fed into
the softmax layer
to actually produce a vector of
probabilities between 0 and 1.
OK?
So now, how do we
train this thing?
So typically, this is used for
natural language processing,
for instance.
So a typical input
will be a character.
And a character will be, again,
one-hot encoded into let's say
100 competent vectors
if we are using--
we will be using
here an alphabet
of 100 possible characters.
So one character is encoded into
a 100 element vector, so 99 0s
and a 1 at the ASCII
index of that character.
So we put a character in.
We propagate through
the neural networks.
the softmax layer.
We obtain a character
as an output.
If that is not the
character we wanted, well,
we compute the difference
between what he said
and what we know to be true and
use retro propagation to fix
the weights and biases inside of
the cell to get better results.
That is very classical training.
But what if the
result was wrong not
because the weights and biases
inside of the cell was wrong,
but because the input, the state
input, H minus 1, was wrong?
That input is a constant
in this problem.
There's not much
you can do about it.
So here, we are stuck.
What is the solution?
Well, the solution is
to replicate the cell.
And now, so this is a replica.
It's reusing the exact
same weights, OK?
Now, let's see the
output, Y1, is bad.
I say, no, that's not it.
This was the correct
output I'm training.
So I know what the correct
output is supposed to be.
So from that, I compute
the enter, the gradient.
I retro propagate.
I can fix the weights
and biases in the cells
to get a better output.
And if needed, I can fix
the weights and biases
to get a better H0, the state
flowing between those two
stages of the cell.
So now, I have a
handle on at least H0.
I still have no handle
at all on H minus 1.
If it is H minus
1 that was wrong,
there is nothing I can do.
So that is how you train
recurrent neural networks.
You have to unroll them
across a certain length
and give them a sequence
of, let's say, characters.
It will produce a sequence
of output characters.
If you are training,
you know what
the answer was supposed to be.
So you use that to compute
your error function,
do you retro propagation,
adjust the weights and biases.
And it will work to
a certain extent.
To what extent?
Oh, yes, small detail,
if you want to go deep,
you can actually
stack the cells.
Why?
Well, two cells stacked like
this, the API remains the same.
It's still an input.
It's still an output that
feeds into a softmax layer.
And there is still an input
state and an output state
that you feedback in.
It's just that the output
state now is slightly bigger.
So that's how you go deep in
the recurrent neural network.
You stack those cells,
and that becomes
a new cell which still
has input, output,
input state, output state.
And of course, you unroll it.
So let's take this sentence.
Let's say now, we use
not characters but words
as our inputs.
Of course, there are
technical problems doing that.
A typical alphabet is
maybe 100 characters.
A typical vocabulary
is around 30,000 words.
So here, one-hot
encoding gives you
a vector of 30,000
components for each word.
It's a bit heavy.
I won't go into the details
of how you handle that.
It's called embedding.
Whatever, let's just assume
that we solved this problem.
So we have this sentence.
Michael was born in Paris,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And at the end, we have
his mother tongue is.
So if we train this
model on English,
probably it will
have figured out
that "his mother
tongue is" is followed
by the name of a
language, like English,
German, or Russian, something.
Here, however,
the correct answer
is French because this
guy was born in France.
So let's imagine
that we feed in,
we have unrolled this
neural network over,
let's say, 30 words.
Or let's say 10
words here, 10 words.
And at the end, we have
his mother tongue is,
and we are asking the network to
predict what is the next word.
And the network says, English.
So now, what we want to
do is put on the outputs
a sentence that says,
blah, blah, blah,
his mother tongue is French.
And do retro propagation.
But for this to
work, the beginning
of the sentence, the part
where the information
about Paris and
where he's born is,
has to be part of that example.
And that example is
longer than 10 words,
which is our unroll size.
There is simply
no way whatsoever
of putting that correct
example plus correct output
into a network that we
unrolled over only 10 words
because the distance
is more than 10.
And that's a
fundamental limitation.
If you want to capture this
information, this behavior
that, if he was born in France,
probably his mother language
is French, you
will have to unroll
this network over a
long enough sequence
to be able to input this
full example into it.
And if you do that, you will
probably unroll it here over,
how many, 50 words?
Something like that.
If you do that, the
problem is that you end up
with a very deep neural network.
Yesterday, we've seen neural
networks of five layers.
The big ones, like
Inception and so on,
are 40, 50, 60, 70 layers.
You see here, we
have a toy example.
And we already
see that we should
be going to 50 or 100
layers just to solve this.
So in recurrent neural
networks, you always
end up using very
deep neural networks.
And when I say deep, it's
because the state signal has
to go through all those cells.
And remember, in each
cell, the state signal
is concatenated
to the input which
goes through a
neural network layer,
produces a new state, which
goes to the next cell, that
is concatenated to the input.
Goes to another
neural network layer.
So from here to the end,
we traverse at least one
neural network layer per cell.
That's how wide and deep.
Deep neural networks
have a technical problem.
They tend not to converge
when you train them.
I won't go into the
mathematical details.
It's called the vanishing
gradient problem.
Basically, your
gradient becomes 0.
And since you use your
gradient to go forward,
that's a bit of a problem.
So a solution was invented.
I won't go into the
mathematical explanations
of why this solution works.
I just want you to
understand how it works.
So would you [INAUDIBLE] an
explanation using the arrow
soup of a diagram on the left?
Or the incomprehensible
equations on the right?
Which one do you prefer?
AUDIENCE: Arrows.
MARTIN GORNER: Arrows?
I'm a developer.
And those equations look
a little bit like code.
And I do code.
Sorry.
But on the arrows, you
see at least one thing.
So I'll do some hand-waving
mathematics again.
You see that the state is
actually split into two.
You have the H state
and the C state.
And the C line there is actually
configured in such a way
that the network can decide
to persist information
on it, to leave it unchanged
from iteration to iteration.
And that is somehow
what explains
that even if you line
up many of those,
since it has the possibility of
leaving some part of the state
unchanged, it goes around those
vanishing gradient problems.
End of hand-waving mathematics.
So let's do it.
Let's see how it
works in practice.
And actually, it's based
on a concept of gates.
So again, we concatenate
the real input to the state
from the previous step.
And we compute three, you
recognize the formulas,
neural network layers.
The sigma is for the
sigmoid activation function.
So the sigma outputs
values between 0 and 1.
And we call those gates
because we will actually
be multiplying these numbers
to another vector to gate it.
You know, if you
multiply something
by a very small value, there's
not much that goes through.
If you multiply something by
something that is close to 1,
almost all of the
information goes through.
So that's how we
will be using them.
Now, our input becomes, well,
we have to size adapt our input.
I put on the side the
sizes of all the vectors
we are working with.
That's just to tell you that
there is nothing to see there.
Inside of the cell,
everything is of size n.
That's the parameter
that you decide
as the size of your cell, OK?
But our inputs, they
are what they are.
So we first need one
neural network layer
to adapt the size of
our inputs to size n.
So that becomes our new input.
And now, the C line,
the way you read this,
this is a kind of memory.
So the new state
of the memory is
the old state of the
memory without what
we chose to forget.
We multiply by this forget gate.
This is a series of
numbers between 0 and 1.
Plus what we chose to
remember from our new input.
That's the way to read it.
So we multiply our new
input by the update gate.
Again, numbers
between 0 and 1 that
shows which part
of the information
we want to retain from this
input into our internal memory.
And then, our new state
is simply the memory--
the hyperbolic
tangent here, that's
not a neural network layer.
That's just a size adaptation
to put it between minus 1 and 1.
So it's basically
the memory cell
multiplied by the result gate.
So here, we choose what
part of our internal memory
we want to expose to
the outside as a result.
So that's the physical
interpretation
of these equations.
We have those three gates.
We size adapt our input.
And then, the new memory
is the old memory minus
what we want to forget
plus what we want
to remember from the input.
And the result is this
memory cell modulo
what we want to actually expose
as an output at that step.
OK?
And now, this HT will actually
become part of the new state,
and also drive the
softmax layer if we
add a softmax layer,
which is represented here
by this yellow circle.
We usually represent the softmax
layer as external to a cell.
So this is called an LSTM.
And this was
invented specifically
to make recurrent
neural networks work
and to solve this depth
problem that, if you
are unrolling over
a large sequence,
they tended not to converge.
You will have to believe me
on the mathematics with this.
They converge.
But you will have to--
I'm sure someone noticed
that this choice of equations
and this choice of arrows
was somehow arbitrary.
I mean, why point them
here and not there?
Many combinations exist.
Lots of different variations
of those R and N cells
have been devised.
And someone published
a paper, a recap paper,
where he tested all of
them and found them to do
all exactly the same thing.
So in the end, the one
we use is called the GRU.
And I won't go into the details.
It's basically a cheaper LSTM.
Here are the equations.
Not very different.
Same API.
But only two gates
instead of three gates.
And each gate has
weights and biases.
So we save a part of
our computational cycle
not computing those
third weights and biases.
OK, so we will use the GRU.
And now, let's implement
a neural network
that does a language model.
So we will be training on
sequences of characters.
And when I say language
model, it's actually a network
that we will use to predict--
we will train it to predict
what the next character is.
Like here, St. Joh,
I will teach it
to produce the same
sequence shifted by one.
So actually, I will
teach it to understand
that the next character
should be an "n" because this
is St. John.
So how do we do that?
In TensorFlow, now I'm using a
higher level API of TensorFlow
than what I had been
using yesterday.
I just call GRUCell.
That creates a GRU cell.
And I call this higher
level, because you've
seen this GRU cell has actually
a couple of neural network
layers inside.
It has two gates.
That's at least two layers.
So it has a host of
weights and biases
which are actually defined
in the background when
I call this.
That's why it's a
higher level API.
It does its own weights and bias
declarations in the background.
Now, I said we want to go deep.
So let's stack this
cell three high.
That's how we do deep
recurrent neural networks.
Three is a TensorFlow
call for that.
It's called MultiRNNCell.
Give it a cell.
You say how many times
you want to stack it.
And that gives you another cell.
Because we have seen already
that these three stacked
cells actually have the
same API as one cell.
So you can use it as a new cell.
And now, we need to unroll this.
For that, we call
in TensorFlow flow
this dynamic RNN function,
which is a bit of magic.
And that's what will
unroll this sequence.
So how many times?
You don't see it
in the parameters
because it's actually specified
in the shape of the input
tensor, x.
If this input tensor
has eight or let's
say 30 characters
in it, it will be
unrolled over a sequence
of 30 characters.
And actually, the
little part of magic,
really it's magic, we
will not be using it here,
but this dynamic RNN,
what it can do also,
remember that we will be
training this on batches,
as always.
We always train on batches.
So in this case,
all my batches will
be sequences of the same size.
That's the case in my model.
In other models,
I might not have
sequences of the same size.
Dynamic RNN can handle that.
If you pass it a
batch of sequences,
even if they are not
of the same size,
alongside that you
pass the actual sizes,
and it will, for each
sentence in the batch,
unroll your network the
correct number of times.
And then, also pass the
output from the correct stage.
It's super helpful.
Will not be using it here
because all of our sequences
have the same size.
But that is super helpful.
All right, so now, we need to
implement our softmax layer
from those H double
second 0 to H second 8.
Well, basically the
outputs at the bottom.
We know how to do a
softmax layer, OK?
But here, since
we have unrolled,
remember each stack here is
a copy of the previous one.
We are sharing the weights.
So on the softmax side, we have
to share the weights, as well.
So we could do this using
the TensorFlow APIs.
You know, define
one softmax layer.
And then, for the
next one, call an API
that retrieves the weights
of the previous one
and reuses them.
That's too complicated here.
Actually, there is a little
hack that you can use.
Remember, we are always
training on batches, OK?
So this will be taking
a batch of sequences,
outputting a batch of sequences.
Each sequence is a
sequence of characters.
So what is the difference
between having,
let's say, 8 softmax cells that
each process a batch of 100
characters, or having just
one that process 800 of them?
That's the same thing.
Let's just do one.
And we will put all of those
outputs in the same bag
and just use that one cell.
Anyway, we were supposed
to be sharing the weights,
so defining just one cell is
a very good way of doing that.
So that's what I do with
my reshape operation there.
I take all of those outputs.
and you have to remember that
there is a batch of outputs
on each of those arrows.
And I put them in the same bag.
Feed them through just
one softmax layer.
And then, I will reshape them
back into the correct shape
to finish.
Again, using higher
level APIs in TensorFlow,
so when I call linear, that
just does the weighted sums.
One layer, it computes
simply the weighted sums.
No activation function.
And then, I called softmax.
And that applies the
softmax activation function.
And linear, again, defines
the weights and biases
in the background.
That's why I call it a
higher level function.
And now, I'm ready to
compute my loss function
and derive it and actually
train the network.
It's just as complicated
to understand how
recurrent neural networks work.
And it's just as
complicated to actually feed
them data correctly.
You see lots of arrows.
So we will have to do
quite a bit of plumbing
to make this happen.
Let's try to get our inputs
and outputs right, OK?
So we will be inputting
sequences of characters
by batches.
So my inputs are a
batch of sequences.
The sequence length that
I have chosen is 30.
I will be unrolling
over 30 characters.
Usually, on the diagrams,
I only represent 8 of them
because 30 would
not fit on my slide.
But in the code, it was 30.
Now, I need to
one-hot encode them.
So I'm adding a new size.
Each character becomes a
vector of 100 components
because I am working
with an alphabet of 100
possible characters.
So now, it's batch
size, sequence length,
and alpha size.
Those are my actual inputs.
My state, again, I
have a batch of states.
Since I'm feeding in
a batch of inputs,
I will produce a batch
of output states.
And the states, each
of those state vectors
is, of course, of size
n, cell size, whatever
cell size I have chosen to use.
Remember, each cell has this
one configuration parameter,
which is its internal size.
But since I have stacked
those cells three high,
it will actually-- the
actual output state here will
be three times the cell size.
OK, we are ready to
write this model.
So I define a placeholder
for my input sequences,
a batch of sequences of
size, sequence, length.
I one-hot encode
them, which is why
I'm adding a new size
to this tensor, which
is the size of my alphabet.
Again, each character becomes
a vector of 100 components.
To be really precise, my alpha
size is 98, so 98 components.
I'm working with an alphabet
of 98 characters here.
I need to define a placeholder
for my correct answers.
And actually, the
correct answers
are very easy to obtain here.
I'm just teaching it to output
the same sequence shifted
by one.
So basically, to predict what
the last character will be.
So again, the
correct answers will
be a batch of sequences
of 30 characters, which
I one-hot encode.
I need a placeholder
also for my input state.
And we have seen that the
batch of input states,
we have seen that the input
state is made of three
of those internal vectors.
So that's three times cell size.
And now, I'm ready
to write my model.
So the model is
what was here, OK?
That's the model.
This model, with this little
trick that we have seen before,
this model at the output
of its softmax layer
actually produces an output
that is batch size multiplied
by sequence length.
You remember, we put all the
characters from the batches
and from the different stages
of the unrolled sequence
in the same bag.
And now, to determine characters
from those probabilities,
I use argmax.
Why?
Because each of those
vectors is 100 components
with probabilities.
Argmax is a function that gives
me the index of the biggest
number in this vector.
So the index in this
victory is actually
the ASCII code of the character
that has been predicted.
So these are my
predictions now in ASCII
encoding in characters.
And I just need to reshape
them back to have, again,
a batch of sequences of
30 predicted characters.
And now, I'm ready to input--
to give my loss to an optimizer
and ask TensorFlow to optimize
to actually train my network.
So this is the step, as
yesterday, with this loss.
TensorFlow computes a gradient.
From this gradient, it can--
sorry.
And this loss is, of
course, the difference
between the sequence of
characters that was predicted
and the sequence of characters
that I wanted to predict.
This difference becomes a loss.
That loss is derived,
becomes a gradient.
We take a small step
along this gradient,
which is actually in the
space of weights and biases.
So taking a small step means
we modify slightly our weights
and biases and continue.
That's the training.
One last little gotcha.
So we have to take
our input text
and actually cut it up in those
sequences of 30 characters.
So initially, I thought,
well, that's easy, you know?
You take a piece of text.
How do you cut it up in
sequences of characters?
Well, you cut, and
cut, and cut, and cut.
And then, if you
need a batch of them,
you take the first 100
sequences you have.
And you put that in a batch.
That did not work.
Why?
Let's see here.
That's my first batch.
Let's see the first
sequence in the batch?
The quick-- you know
what that is going to be.
The quick brown fox something.
Well, when my neural
network processes the quick,
it also outputs an output state.
And in the next iteration,
that output state
will become the input state
for the next sequence.
If I want this to be
correct, that input state
must correspond to
the continuation
of the quick brown
fox, and so on,
which means that
the sentence has
to continue over all of
the first slots of all
of my batches.
It's a not completely
trivial way of batching here.
You cut up your text in
batches, in sequences.
But the way to
batch them together,
since you have to pass the
correct state at each stage,
is that the
beginning of the text
has to be split across
the first item in batches.
And then, from some point far,
far, far later in the text,
you can start filling the
second line of the batches.
It's just plumbing.
I wrote for you the five
lines of code that does this.
It's five lines.
I spent four hours doing
it, including tests.
I don't do arithmetic.
It's full of
modulos and divides.
And I wrote unit
tests and hacked it
until the unit tests passed.
It's called
test-driven debugging.
Sorry, test-driven development.
That's what developers do.
All right, so yeah, small
gotcha on the batching.
But whatever.
Just use the code on--
this is not actually important.
Just use the function that
will cut up the text correctly
for you.
And you're ready to train.
And this is actually the full
code of this neural network
on one slide.
So let's go through this again.
A placeholder for
my input sequences.
I one-hot encode them.
I'm actually inputting
sequences of characters, OK?
And all the people with
cameras, this is on GitHub.
And the GitHub link
is on the last slide.
So please take pictures.
My Twitter handle is over there.
Tweet them.
But then, you will be able
to go and GitHub and actually
retrieve this.
Then, my expected
outputs, why underscore?
Again, I define a
placeholder for them.
I will need to feed
them during training.
And the first thing I do is
that I one-hot encode them.
I will also need,
and this is different
from normal neural
networks, I will also
need a placeholder
for my input state.
Remember?
RNNs have an input
and an input state.
Two inputs.
Now, I'm ready to
write my model.
So I chose the GRU cell.
I stack it three high.
And I unroll it as many times
as x has components in it.
So here, my unroll size
is sequence length.
And that's 30.
I chose 30 characters
as the unroll size
of my recurring neural network.
I do my little trick
with the softmax
so that I can implement
just one softmax node.
I feed the output
through my softmax node.
Here, I apply argmax to retrieve
from the softmax probabilities
the highest probability.
And that's the character
I'm predicting.
I reshape this back to have a
batch of predicted sequences.
Also, somewhere in
the middle in there,
I had those probabilities.
I take those probabilities.
And I compute the distance
between what it says
and what I wanted.
That's my loss.
I give my loss to the optimizer.
I obtain a training step.
And this training
step is actually
that gradient, which is computed
on this batch of training
characters.
And which, if I follow
it by a little step,
will modify my
weights and biases
and bring me to somewhere where
this network works better,
where it has a smaller
error function.
And now, my training loop.
You will see, this is
very familiar to what
we had previously.
We use this magic
plumbing function
that I gave you to load
sequences of characters
in the correct way.
And once I have a
sequence of characters,
I run session.run
of my training step.
I have to give it
the input characters.
the expected output.
And, since this is a
recurrent neural network,
I have to give it
the input state.
And this will give
me an output state.
And you see the
magic line, why this
is a recurrent neural network.
That's the last line
there in the red.
Input state becomes--
sorry, the output state
becomes an input state.
That's why it's recurrent.
They're passing
the state around.
All right.
So we are done.
We've built a recurrent
neural network.
Now, we want to
actually train it.
So let's go to a demo.
I will be training this on
the complete works of William
Shakespeare.
That's not quite big data.
The complete works of William
Shakespeare are five megabytes.
Yes, that puts things
in perspective.
But it's good stuff.
So here, we see it's
training on sequences.
So here are those
sequences of 30 characters.
And here's a batch of them.
It's actually training
on those sequences.
Here, predicting
not much at all.
It's just the beginning.
And from time to time,
I stop the training.
And I take just my one cell.
Remember, I have just one cell.
It's replicated for the
purpose of training,
but it's just one cell.
And this one cell,
it has become--
well, once it will be
trained, it will have become--
a language model.
So what I can do with it is
generate a new Shakespeare
play.
How do I do that?
Well, I take the cell.
I put in garbage,
a random character.
That gives me an
output character.
Probability of an
output character,
which is the next character,
and an output state.
You feed back the output
state in the input,
and I feed back the output
character as the new input.
And I continue.
And this is a state machine
that will start generating text.
You see here, it's--
yeah.
That's not quite
Shakespeare yet.
It's training.
It's a bit slow on my machine.
I usually have a
GPU connected here
to-- it brings me a nice
10x speed, or 6x roughly.
But still, well, it has
done 50 more batches.
I will leave it running.
Let's go and see, sorry, here.
On this slide, what it is.
So at the beginning,
it gives you this.
As I said, not
quite Shakespeare.
But after only an epoch,
what we call an epoch,
it's when you have seen the
entire training data set once.
So after having
seen only a tenth
of what Shakespeare produced in
his life, this is what we have.
Still not quite
Shakespeare, but you see
there is some structure to it.
After two tenths, hey,
this looks better!
It's starting to actually
spell English almost correctly.
And there are those
things in capital letters
at the beginning
that are starting
to look like characters,
like character names.
Even slightly later, oh, look!
And you have to
remember that this
is a neural network that
is predicting character
by character.
It first has to learn to
spell English before going
to higher orders of structure.
So it's still not
completely exact English.
But it's starting to
look like English.
At least, Shakespearean English.
And you see it has
character names.
And it's actually inventing
new character names.
Here, Pordia and Henry Blutius--
who can tell me,
no, seriously, who
can tell me if
Shakespeare actually
used Henry Blutius in his work?
What do you call it?
I'm giving you the answer.
He didn't.
But it's a very credible
Shakespearean character name.
And this is what you
get after 30 epochs.
So it actually has a title.
There is an act.
There's a scene.
After the scene, it tells
you where this is happening.
And look, it knows how
to put scenic indications
in brackets, who enters,
with whom, and so on.
It has even picked up stuff
like, character names are
all caps, and when the character
is a function, like Lord
or Chamberlain, it's
only the first character
that is a capital.
It has picked up completely
correctly as well.
And it's actually English.
So now that we have
this, let's try to--
so this was on slides.
I will stop this.
What I have done previously
is that I trained
this for actually 30 epochs.
And I saved my
weights and biases.
So I'm ready to just replay it
and generate a new Shakespeare
play.
Let's generate a new one
live in front of you.
Here it is.
Let me stop it.
Whoops, sorry about that.
[APPLAUSE]
MARTIN GORNER: Is
someone brave enough
to come and play hallucinated
Shakespeare on the stage
with me?
Come on.
Yes!
Thank you.
Big applause.
SPEAKER: Come on up?
MARTIN GORNER: Thank you.
Please, come up.
You will have to speak loudly.
But that's how it
is in a theater.
You don't have a microphone.
You speak.
So you can read off
the screen here.
We will alternate.
So maybe I start, and
then you do the next one.
So let's say enter
Bardolph and Boult.
The manner off with my bestowers
that you shall not see him,
and we are now to be the
brother's wife and force,
to be so many and most grave.
SPEAKER: What art thou again?
What needs thy life?
Then, what they do
not dote on thee.
The word will be at thee.
And take my heart to thee.
And they distemper.
Will thou beat me well
to say god save my son?
[APPLAUSE]
MARTIN GORNER:
Thank you so much.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
MARTIN GORNER: Thank you.
That was fantastic.
Thank you.
Actually, I tried to do
this also on the Python code
of TensorFlow itself.
That was fun.
So in the beginning,
you had this.
Looks like Python?
Maybe.
But very, very
quickly, it actually
picks up Pythonic structures,
like those keywords,
and it's generating something
that looks like function calls.
Slightly later, it actually
correctly uses the keywords
with function names-- a
hallucinated function name.
It's actually quite inventive
in the function names.
And a colon at the end.
It's still getting the
nested parenthesis wrong.
And after a longer while, it
can recite the Apache license
in full.
Yes.
It's open source compliant,
open source compliant.
And more interestingly
for us, designers
of recurrent neural networks,
it can actually close and open
the nested parentheses
right to a depth of three,
which is quite impressive.
And what I find fantastic,
it's that it has figured out
how to do Python comments.
And it's giving me TensorFlow
advice in those comments.
But look, it makes sense!
Check that we have
both scalar tensors
for being invalid
to a vector of one
indicating the total
loss of the same shape
as the shape of the tensor.
I'm sure this makes just
as much sense as everything
that I've been saying
since the beginning here.
All right, and small
credits to a gentleman
called Andrej
Karpathy who actually
wrote this neural network
for the first time.
He published a blog about it.
He tried it on many
different things.
He generated a business
book for startups.
And he tried to generate
an algebra book in LaTeX.
Actually, after training, this
produced almost valid LaTeX.
So he had to hack it a little
bit to make it compile.
But then, this looks
like an algebra book.
That is even an
attempt at a diagram.
And the line I prefer is
how the neural network
solved how to write a proof.
Look at the very top.
"Proof omitted."
That's so clever.
All right.
So that's basically all
I wanted to show you.
Well, this is how
we generate it.
So we, I take just one cell.
And basically, in a loop,
I feed in a character.
I take the output, feed
it back as the input,
and feed the output
state as the input state,
and just do this in a loop.
A couple of
applications of this.
Oh, yes.
Actually, we still have
a little bit of time.
This time, I've been using
TensorBoard to visualize
my inputs and outputs.
Where is my TensorBoard?
Somewhere.
Sorry, I'll find it.
Here.
In the last session, I was
just throwing the outputs
into matplotlib, which is the
very standard Python plotting
library.
But there is a tool dedicated
to visualizing training
in TensorFlow.
It's called TensorBoard.
And I advise you to
use it, especially
if you do a distributed
training, or training
on remote servers.
It can connect to a bucket and
get the information from there
and visualize it.
So here again, I
have configured,
when I was training
this network,
I configured it to actually
do training and validation.
I put one Shakespeare
play aside for validation
to test my network.
And if you'll remember the
session from yesterday,
I find it very important to
follow my loss curves, both
the training and the test
loss curve, on the screen.
This is what I got.
And actually, first of all,
who sees something wrong?
Overfit, yeah.
And so now, the question is,
why is it overfitting here?
I will give you the answer
because you can't guess it.
But here, I was actually
training on a small subset
of the Shakespeare corpus.
So here, it was overfitting
because of lack of data.
And since I had
this on the curves,
I wanted to show it to you
because you certainly remember
that somewhere, where is it?
This one.
Somewhere here, I had this
helpful engineering chart.
Which allows you to interpret
what overfitting is.
And we went yesterday
through the bad network.
We went through
too many neurons.
We never had not enough data.
So I tried with not enough data.
And yes, it also gives you
this very recognizable pattern
in the curves.
And as soon as I train with
more data, this is what I have.
So here, the two curves
follow each other closely.
And I know that I have
solved the problem.
So actually, I was
doing this because I
was trying to add
dropout into my network
to make it work better.
No.
It was misbehaving just
because of lack of data.
Dropout would not
have solved that.
All right, and so a
couple of applications,
practical applications
to finish.
We've seen how to produce a
character by character model.
We can also use this not
character by character,
but word by word.
So as I said
previously, with a word,
it's a bit more complicated
because to one-hot encode
a word, you need to encode
it on a vector of, this time,
30,000 components.
Because that's the typical
size of a vocabulary,
typical language.
So those are big.
So on the inputs,
there is actually
a very simple solution.
How do you reduce the
size of a big vector?
Well, you use one layer
of a neural network
and produce less outputs.
It's called embeddings.
And that layer can either
be part of your training--
then, your embeddings
are learned
as part of the training.
Or, you can use
some neural network
that has been already
trained, typically trained
on the English
language generically,
and that just encodes
words into smaller vectors.
There is a very
famous, what is it,
neural network that has
been built for that.
It's called Word2Vec.
Already trained,
available on GitHub.
You can use that to
encode your English words
if your problem deals
with English words
as smaller vectors.
And so once we have
solved this problem of how
to input words
instead of characters,
you can, for example, use
a recurrent neural network
like this to predict not
what the next word is,
but a categorization
of a sequence.
And this is used in newspapers
to automatically categorize
articles as geopolitics,
science, sports, and so on.
Works very well.
How do you do translation?
Well, to do translation, that's
how Google Translate works,
you tack two of those
recurrent networks end to end.
To the first one, you
apply an English sentence
plus a stop symbol.
And then, you continue.
And you ask it to output
the French sentence.
And what you have on the
input, there is a choice.
Normally, you
should be inputting
what your network outputs.
But people have
also tried to input
what the network should output.
So both options exist.
And they give you
different results.
You can read about
this in literature.
So this is how
translation works.
Of course, you have a
big problem at the end.
I won't go into that.
Because to do the
softmax layers there,
you actually want to produce a
vector of 30,000 probabilities.
That's a bit heavy.
So there are ways
of mitigating that.
But that's an active
area of research.
One that is implemented
in TensorFlow
is called sample softmax.
But there are many
others because this
is an active area of research.
How to do this softmax layer
to produce 30,000 probabilities
each time, which is a bit heavy.
And one more is image labeling.
So here, it's a very simplified
version of image labeling.
Image labeling is
you take an image,
and you want to
produce a sentence.
Like, this a little girl
holding a teddy bear.
This is a truck in the desert.
So this is actually also
a translation problem.
You take vectors from an image.
And you apply a
recurrent neural network
to produce a sequence
of words which
you want to be the
description of this image.
How do you encode an
image as a vector?
Well, there are
plenty of solutions.
One of them is to
take an off the shelf
image recognition neural
network, like Inception,
and just chop off the
last couple of layers.
Normally, what Inception
gives is categories.
This is a truck.
This is a beach.
This is a lizard.
That's not what you want.
But all the top
layers are actually
encoding an image in some
meaningful way into a vector.
You can use that as a
fixed encoding function.
And input the vector
corresponding to the image
here.
Produce this output sequence.
And sometimes, it
works really well.
This is what was generated.
A herd of elephants walking
across a dry grass field,
and so on.
And then sometimes,
yeah, not quite.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]